on
cole's album like when i first pressed
play i don't think you could see the
features on there when i i don't know
however i was listening i couldn't see
any of the features
right so i was just pressing play and
then i went on twitter and i was like yo
that was boss
like yeah dipping into your melody back
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah you know just trying to grow
out the comfort zone i was down there
with cole
um that's one thing you know we were
kind of preaching
and throughout that whole process we
actually did the jackie like those same
like three four days that i was down
there working on
so that that record happened during the
off season sessions
yeah yeah it was like cole has like a
very set time he'd be in the studio
right he got a lot of other things going
on so we had like 30 minutes left
i think we had just finished doing like
some background vocals
on one of the records might be like let
go of my hand and um
he was like yo let's pull up a beat and
just like do something like 30.
so he pulled up a t-minus folder first b
he played was the jackie
and we just looked at each other like
yeah like don't say less like
pull that one up yeah got on the mic and
um
you know just challenging ourselves not
to
to feel some things you know what i mean
as opposed to like be so clinical with
the writing and
just trying to push yourself out of that
comfort zone like i'm usually the type
to sit there and like
get all my words right and then be like
all right you know i'm ready to do my
verse and it was like you know what not
just get on there
and do what you feel you know what i
mean do like what comes to you like
naturally
and then you know you can refine it from
there and go back and and work on how
clever you want to make it
or whatnot but there's certain things
you can't replace you know and that's
something like
i'll even watch like some of the some of
the younger kids now
that's all they do you know that's all
they do they'll just go fill out the
beat in the booth yeah and then
worry about filling in the lyrics and
[ __ ] later yeah right right and there's
there's
you know i feel like there's something
to learn from everyone's process for
sure
now something i was able to kind of
apply to myself like you know just
just let loose a little bit like don't
even think about it what's the melody
that comes to you what
you know what i mean what's the feeling
that comes to you and you know we did
the jackie in like 30 minutes